[Music]
the United States stands for an idea
whose time is now Ronald Reagan will win
tonight what a schmuck
I think I want to be an artist when I
grow up gonna be an artist if you want
to be nothing's going to stop you you're
going to college he'll have dinner with
Kings if he plays his cards right
I really like your stickers my
stepfather gave them to me he's in the
Air Force that's so cool
how dare you a menace to you
are you not to associate with him again
what do you mean why
I think you know what I mean
my parents are sending me to my
brother's school that's heavy
in this institution you can be anything
you want to be it won't be because of a
handout it'll be because you earned your
way there
someone's bugging you what is it
sometimes kids say bad words about the
black kids who's that somebody from my
old school
did they ever come to your house what'd
you do when that happens obviously
nothing of course
you think that's my
why'd she come here because I wanted to
kill her that's why
soldiers and sometimes they go out
looking for Jews
so I got on the boat and we came over
here to America the land of dreams
you just wanted to be like you I want
you to be a whole lot better than me
life is unfair be thankful when you get
a leg up you make the most of your break
and do not look back all my hopes are
with you and your brother in my whole
life
[Music]
[Applause]
next time those Schmucks are anything
bad about those kids you're gonna say
something
that'd be a match okay firm handshake
okay give me a hug
and he'll just die cancer and I don't
really care mom she's your sister I know
but you know what a bet she is
are you thinking what I'm thinking Aunt
Hilda is Never Gonna Write us into her
will she doesn't even like us she
doesn't like anybody in case you haven't
noticed our business is going down the
tubes and our lives are falling apart
let's go get rich from that dying old
[ __ ]
[Music]
we heard you weren't well and you think
this side of you two is gonna cheer me
up are you Dim
oh cousin Beatrice is here from New York
huh and she thinks that the sun shines
out of my ass we know why you're here do
you think we look like idiots do you
really want me to answer that question
hey cousins what's up no I wouldn't lose
touching that hold on I'm not a complete
idiot amazing Mercy you are looking
really really fine so Richard pour me
dick I like dick now dick oh you like
dick now I prefer dick you seem to have
caught the sun today Hilda you've got a
little bit of a glow it's jaundice
it looks good on you
[Music]
you're trying to take our money I was
just out buying flowers for my favorite
aunt oh thank you
I'll probably never feel a man inside me
again if I wasn't your nephew I'd be
only too happy to be inside you if we
get her laid by her High School Crush we
have a shot have you ever thought about
sex with an older woman
[Applause]
I'm not gonna do it it's you I'm so
selfish
[Music]
Richard
just have fun with it
well I have completely lost time before
doing here
what the hell is wrong with you people
we have always had a thing you and me
our thing B that we're in the same
family they were just cousins cousins
are very gay maybe even have some kids
not naturally you know in case they came
out weird
[Music]
[Music]
only the most broken people
[Music]
can't be great leaders
all right
they call him
the feather serpent Court
killing him will risk Eternal War
is coming
for the surface world
I know what you whispered
foreign
[Music]
the only way these women are going to go
on the record is if they all jump
together
why is sexual harassment so pervasive
and so hard to address
let's interrogate the whole system hi my
name is Jody Cantor I'm an investigative
reporter for the New York Times
what have you got I was told that the
wrongdoing in Hollywood is overwhelming
I don't want to be quoted period
understood
in your previous stories how did you
persuade women to tell you what had
happened to them a case I made was I
can't change what happened to you in the
past but together we may be able to help
protect other people
the truth basically
what is it exactly that we're looking at
here these young women walked into what
they all had reason to believe were
business meetings
I can still see it the hotel room the
floor plan he kept trying to touch me I
asked him to leave me alone instead they
say he met them with threats and sexual
demands I was young scared hi we're from
The New York Times I believe he used to
work for Harvey Weinstein
people have tried to write this story
before he kills it every time Harvey
adamantly denies any allegation of
assault he played people he was a master
manipulator will you give me just one
chance to talk to you
sure that this isn't just young women
who want to sleep with a movie producer
to try to get ahead this is
the women who receive these settlements
they can't speak out they'll be sued if
they do but if someone could speak
freely about the payouts
what payouts John
you have to imagine that every call you
make has been recorded and you're being
followed can you imagine how many
Harveys there are out there you want to
get me killed
do you wish you hadn't signed up for
this story do you no the only way these
women are going to go on the record is
if they all jump together
we're all here Harvey oh
Tim I have three daughters and
accept abuse or bullying
I'll go on the record
all right it's time to write
this is all going to come up
silenced
I want my voice
is that gonna fit everyone easily 12
customers total how do they turn a
profit 12.50 ahead that's how what are
we eating a Rolex
it's one of his classics
you have to try the mouse feel of the
minionette please don't say mouthful
tonight will be Madness
welcome
we'll Endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to Hawthorne
Here We are family
we Harvest we ferment we jump
wait gel we gel
he's not just a chef he's a Storyteller
the game is trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be you won't know until the end
who are you I am Marco
how do you care I have to know if you're
with us or with them
this menu the pictures
how do they get these it's not good this
entire evening
Jesus Christ it was just theater it's
stage crowd we're leaving now has been
painstakingly planned
this is realism what the hell is going
on
we now offer you a 45 second Head Start
okay 45 seconds Starts Now
this is what you're paying for
get out of my way
it's all part of the menu
no we're gonna die today
[Music]
you told him it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
hey Rick are you following what's
happening in Thailand
some kids stuck in a cave
[Music]
we're on the list of rescue divers
tourist cave it looks easy but when it's
flooded it's impossible
takes a certain kind of mindset for the
Deep cave diving you have to be a bit
nuts they're very very dangerous high
water level and the low visibility
barely shoulder wide pulling against
very strong carrots
how many days ago 12 boys and their
coach are trapped in the flooding cage
[Music]
hey
we're here how many of you thirteen
thirteen they're all alive uh can we go
out now
you're talking about father died
you try and dive those kids the whole
way all you could bring it out is dead
bodies
I'm running low the entire nation is
anxiously waiting for what will happen
next
just a crazy idea but a skill none of
the rest of us have no
it's insane it's unethical it's illegal
man's already died
but do nothing we'll be bringing them
out there for sure so you are expecting
casualties
yes
[Music]
Johnny okay yeah I'm okay just give me a
minute
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I will break you
I promise
[Music]
no I need my birth certificate
I need you to help me I want to be a
Marine
Marine
no you ain't scarier than two left shoes
and everybody can see it
unwounded or injured in this attack
including several Americans
this all I have left
of the dream I held for you
the question is
why do you want to be here
that's not good enough to be a good
Marine means to know thyself and seek
self-improof that means you give it hi
sir
they kicked you out didn't they my mom
she won't even talk to me
most of my friends are dead or in jail
if I die in this uniform
I'm a hero
somebody
who can't be supposed to break you down
on a golf ball if we leave they win why
is this weapon your best friend recruit
because it's the thing that protects the
Marine to my left and to my right sir
I could have left you at any doorstep
I have never giving up on us
[Music]
foreign
what is the president doing in our front
yard our entire world is in grave danger
I want you to come with me on an
expedition I'm not my father he was the
Explorer I know you were just a kid when
you went missing but now you're all we
got Mr clade I'm a huge fan thank you of
your dad
where in the world are we Ethan you
brought the dog he just wants a help
yeah
we are clearly in Uncharted Territory
uh hello you probably don't understand a
word I'm saying of course I understand
you huh
dad dad Grandpa I'm a grandpa all the
trees what is this place the cliffs are
alive and the waters resolve the flesh
off your bones uh is this thing
dangerous
[Music]
I want to merchandise it
they're basically the same person
are you okay
hold
on
come on we got a world to save let's get
moving
it's just a nightmare tunnel just be
brave
[Music]
over the no around there yeah
[Music]
but you can't spend the night not all
night so where'd you move here from
anyway
Eastern Shore
[Music]
try that
[Music]
you didn't when the cops get here you
have to be good and gone I can't help
you anymore I know it's not your fault
you were born this way you hate them I
believed you had to I don't know why
foreign
I don't want to hurt anybody
famous last words
[Music]
it's less I don't actually make money
[Music]
here I am nice
okay I'm looking for you I smelled you
you could smell me half mile away
can you do that not that far I got a
rule never never ever eat an eater
thought you might be hungry for hands no
who lives here is there someone dead up
there
[Music]
I'm not gonna be like that we don't have
many options either you eat you off
yourself or you lock yourself up in
there we're dangerous
one of us Jake's teaching me how to
smell other eaters but we can hurt one
another just as bad
was too much
you gotta do this we have to do it
you've been following me and we got
unfinished business
you know I'm thinking of a bad person
[Music]
oh I think is that I love you
movies are dreams
[Music]
that you never forget
Sammy
[Music]
foreign
looks
[Music]
it's hard to find our house
harsh is the dark house with no lights
it's first the
Sammy's on my team takes after me
[Music]
what kind of movie You're Gonna Make
[Music]
You dismissed what he does it's playful
or imaginative
you could afford to be a little
encouraging
she should have been a concert piano
player but she got in her heart is what
you got you can't just
have to take care of it it's more
important than your hobby can you stop
calling it a hobby
you always have to be the center of
attention stop shouting at her that has
been nothing but disrespect from you I'm
Your Mother
family Art Product it'll tear you into
you stop making movies that'll break
your mother's heart I don't know what to
do anymore you do what your heart says
you have
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
Nicholas has come to live with me and
he's improving but he's a little fragile
so why you came to see me you're blaming
me for what happened
he's different from the others what
makes you say that why don't you answer
me I do answer you the look in his eye
is disturbing she wants to turn us
against one another
[Music]
back then there is so much joy in our
family I feel like a complete failure if
I'm like this it's your fault what have
I done what's my fault haven't I always
done everything for you I have the right
to reinvent my life it is my life
[Music]
everything okay at home
yeah
everything's fine